-Our next guest is
a Tony-nominated actor
who you know, from movies like
"Inside Out";
and shows like "Big Mouth,
"Spin City,"
and "Documentary Now!"
You can catch him on season
of "Everything's Gonna Be Okay,"
which airs Thursdays
on Freeform.
New episodes are available
the following day on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-Hello. Hi, there!
-Well, look at you.
-[ Laughing ]
-You're as tall as can be.
-Thank you.
-I hope you don't mind us
settling in out here.
-No, I don't mind,
but I don't like it.
I mean, my guests stuck
in their car?
How drab!
-We're absolutely fine.
We've got CDs.
-I mean, even with CDs...
There must simply be
more to life
than this driveway to nowhere.
-Oh, we're fine.
Plus, nobody's really trying
to live their lives,
nowadays, are they?
-Uh...
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Richard Kind.
How are you, Richard?
-Oh, Seth, I didn't know you -
Oh.
-[ Laughing ]
-I'm so upset
I'm not in-studio because
need a fourth of these.
-You do get a free mug
every time you're here,
but we refuse to give it
for people
who don't have the courage
to come to the studio.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm doing very well.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing great.
You've been very busy.
You've kept busy
during this year
where a lot of people haven't.
-I got to tell you,
since July, just working.
I, you know, grew a beard
to play a scientist
who's living
out in the wilderness --
not a comedy -- who's got
military secrets for aliens.
And I had this beard and I go,
"Well, why not?"
And so the part
didn't call for it,
but you know me,
I just meet the thing halfwa
-[ Laughs ]
-and I'll, "Hey,
it's got a beard!
Oh, okay. Why not?"
-Is there anyone you were
aiming for with the beard?
Is there anybody
you were trying to emulate
Because it's very unique.
-I am the president of the
Mandy Patinkin Fan Club.
[ Laughter ]
No.
It grows in like this!
I don't know.
I will tell you this.
Believe it or not,
I tried to dye it one time
dye the hair.
-Yeah.
-And have you seen old ladie
with blue in their hair?
That's what happens.
And I didn't know
and I didn't do it --
And I go get one
of those things and go,
"Oh, no, no, no, no, no!"
And I just washed it
very quickly and it didn't take.
But it grows in weird.
It's like Hemingway, you know?
-I like the idea
of you playing a scientist
that has military secrets
about aliens.
Is Richard Kind someone
who believes in aliens?
-No. No.
-Okay.
-I do not,
although I got to tell you
the guy who directed it,
his name is Thomas DeLonge
Tom DeLonge.
He was a singer for Blink-182.
-Mm-hmm.
-He loves aliens!
He loves UFOs.
Has met with the Pentagon.
And the whole time
we're shooting --
and he's a lovely guy
and a good director,
everything like that.
He was a great skateboarde
and he's a rock 'n' roller
who's a director now, okay
-[ Laughs ]
-So I'm like memorizing lines.
I'm not going to get into parts,
but you know how --
Okay, but I'm memorizing.
I'm in the scene and everything.
He goes --
[ California accent ]
No, no, no, dude, dude!
You got to listen to this story.
There was one time this alien --
I'm going, "Tom! Tom! Direct
Don't tell me your stories
about aliens.
Let me -- I'm working, here!
-[ Laughs ]
And, you know, in between shots,
so, yeah, it was fun.
It was hilarious,
doing this thing.
You never know whether or no
a movie's going to be seen
It's called
"Monsters of California."
I don't know. It's about,
you know, with young kids
and I'm the old guy
who has military secrets.
So that's what I do.
-What about ghosts?
Do you believe in ghosts?
-I used to not.
-Okay.
That's how these stories
always start.
-No, no, no, no, no.
And I used to not,
so, therefore, I'm a convert
At Second City, one time -
Did you work at Second City?
-I never did, no.
-Did your brother?
Did Josh work there,
your brother?
-No.
-No. Okay.
-But I've been there.
I've been there plenty, yeah
-Okay, but the one
in Santa Monica
and, one night, literally,
we're going out for a scene.
I was with Robin Duke --
which tells you how long ago -
and we're holding two chairs
and, all of a sudden,
I feel a chair getting pulle
and I go, "Robin, Robin, stop!
And she's on the other sid
of the stage.
And I could feel myself
getting pulled.
And we go out and we asked -
One night, there was no wa
to get backstage, okay?
And we're working. We're doing
improv, everything like that
We come backstage.
There are chairs on the couch.
All the tapes from previousl
recorded improvs
were scattered on the floor.
And you can't get back there
So, what? I don't know.
And so, do I believe in ghosts
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
But no.
I don't. I don't.
-So you think a ghost hate
the fact that you recorded
improv shows?
They were like,
"These are not --
[ Laughter ]
They're only good
in the moment."
-They're only good in the moment
or for ghosts to knock over.
That's all they are.
They're fodder for --
Yes.
Two, we're left on
because they liked that
particular night of improv
They said, "These are okay
The rest, they're garbage!
Get them out of here!"
-I did not realize we both wen
to Northwestern University
I did not realize one of you
daughters is going there.
-One of my daughters,
my oldest daughter, Skye,
is going to Northwestern,
but she's going by Zoom.
She's in North Carolina.
I feel very bad for these kids
In essence, she's going
for, you know,
DeVry Institute for $75,000.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, she's going
It's very tragic, with the kid
and their learning.
I don't like this.
-Well, I went and, again,
I'd very much like being
with you in person
and I miss being around people
I know you sort of filled ou
your house over this pandemic.
You guys got a dog.
How's dog life?
-We have a dog.
The dog is adorable.
It's a puppy.
-Mm-hmm.
-My advice is get a puppy
at two years of age.
I had a friend who said,
"Old people should be shot
at birth,"
and I feel the same way
about puppies.
Puppies should be born
at two years old.
The dog's name is Wilson.
I want to change the name
to Mistake.
-[ Laughs ]
-Our apartment is a toilet
The cleanest place
in the apartment
is our kitty litter box.
We have two cats and a ferret.
I hate the ferret.
I love all the animals,
but, no.
And you know that, in New York
ferrets are illegal?
-I did not know that.
-So I'm a scofflaw
and I'm and on national tele--
And I hate this ferret.
They say,
"Oh, well, it has a musk."
It doesn't have a musk.
It stinks.
[ Laughter ]
It just smells.
And they're adorable-looking
and they move like this.
They're funny, like dolphins
Hate ferrets.
Love my puppy.
Hate my puppy.
It's just, you know,
puppies are babies born
without diapers.
That's what they are.
-Who talked you into the ferret?
-My daughter,
my youngest daughter.
There was a ferret in her class.
She says, "I want a ferret."
You have a child.
What is it like to say no
to your child?
-It's really hard.
I don't feel like
they're quite old enough
to like have strong desires.
But would you describe yoursel
as a pushover?
Because I am the pushover
of the two parents.
I am. Well, I have to admit,
this dog, the puppy,
was purchased
while I was in L.A.,
and they wanted
to "surprise" me with it.
[ Laughter ]
Okay? And I get this text
from the veterinarian, saying,
"The new dog has an appointmen
this Wednesday at 9:30.
'Y' for yes, 'N' for no,"
and I'm going, "What?"
And then I call up and I go,
"Do we have a puppy?"
And they go,
"Oh, it was a surprise."
-[ Laughs ]
-No! No! Talk to me.
I'm the only logical one
in the family.
Talk to me, first.
It's a horror!
[ Laughter ]
It's just awful!
And it's adorable
and it's so smart.
And it's "Marley & Me"
and I don't know what to do.
It's another baby.
It's a baby without diapers.
It just poops.
Although, so smart,
[ Snapping fingers ] the minut
it came in the house,
onto the pad.
But it doesn't know how to pee
outside or poop outside.
You have to teach a dog to pee
and poop outside.
Who would've thought?
[ Laughter ]
In New York.
Who would've thought?
I mean, I don't know.
I'm a wreck.
-You're going to get
through this.
-No.
-I want to ask you this.
-COVID's a snap.
Puppies, that's --
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh! Yes, what?
-A lot of people --
You know, you have a very --
A lot of people know your voice.
It's very
distinguishable voice
-Yes.
-and I have heard
that you have advice.
You're not an impressionist,
per se,
but you have a way for peopl
to get into a Richard Kind
impression,
if they ever --
-Everybody imitates
Richard Kind.
All of my friends --
Dan Castellaneta, Hank Azaria --
and have done it
and it's funny, funny,
funny, funny.
I can't do it.
I just sound like this.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, one time
I was at a poker game
and they asked --
you'll know how long ago.
There was a show called
"The Commish"
with Michael Chiklis.
I had a recurring role
on the show, so they say,
"Are you going to be playing
next week in the poker game?
And I said, "I can't.
I'm doing a 'Commish.'"
And that has all of the vowels
that you need
[ Laughter ]
to do Richard Kind.
So it's --
And I can't do me,
but when I say,
"I can't.
I'm doing a 'Commish.'"
And that's how I imitate me.
Otherwise,
I just sound like this.
-I remember, once,
you presenting an award
at the Writers Guild Award
-Mm-hmm.
-and it was a very written bit
And I can't remember any
of the details,
except that it did not go
particularly well.
And, when you finished it --
and this is my
Richard Kind impression.
Finished, sort of an awkward
silence. You just went --
[ As Kind ]
Alright!
And that was --
[ Laughter ]
-[ Clap ]
-So I recommend that.
[ As Kind ]
I'm doing a "Commish."
But this is why
I don't do stand-up.
This is why I did improv.
-Yes.
-Because you can't
blame anybody.
In improv, you go,
"Where the hell were you?
Why did you do that?!
Why did you say that?!"
But, you're standing up ther
alone and just go,
"It's my fault."
-Yeah.
I felt like
maybe this was the rare case
where the material did not ris
up to your level.
-And the Writers Guild,
[ Laughter ]
it was not that good.
I remember rewriting
a lot of their stuff
and not using their script
but then I also hosted
the International Emmy Award
this year...
-Oh, wow.
-and I rewrote everything.
It was a disaster.
[ Laughter ]
It was horrible!
But there was no audience.
There was only the world.
It was all over the world,
except there was nobody ther
and you can't play the audience.
You want to ride the audience,
you know?
-Horrible.
-You want to ride the audience
just like a ferret.
-Just like a parrot, baby!
It's just like a ferret.
Hey, Richard, it's always such
a delight to talk to you.
-Please say hi
to your family, please.
-I will, and you to yours.
"Everything's Gonna Be Okay"
airs Thursdays on Freeform